we're asked to rationalize and simplify
and once again rationalize this part
right here just means to get rid of any
of the square roots or any of the
radicals in the denominator so we really
want to get rid of this somehow and it
won't be as simple as multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by the
principal square root of x because if we
did that we would multiply the principal
square root of x times this and that
would get rid of the radical here but
then you would have negative 1 times the
principal squared of x it would still
stick around the denominator so the way
to rationalize something like this where
you have a binomial with a with a
radical in it in the denominator
is to multiply by the this is a fancy
word i'm about to say by the conjugate
of the denominator so you have square
root of x minus 1 and so what you do is
you want to multiply the denominator by
the square root of x
plus 1. and i'll show you in a second
why why we're doing that and of course
anything you multiply the denominator by
you also have to multiply the numerator
by otherwise you're actually changing
the changing the value of the of the
expression
so this is just going to be 1 so we're
just multiplying the whole thing by 1.
and the key that i want to point out is
why this is going to work why does it
make sense to multiply by once again
fancy word the conjugate
and the conjugate will show up mainly
when you're trying to rationalize
denominators like this or when you're
trying to get imaginary numbers outside
of denominators so in this case we want
to get rid of a radical and in future
videos we'll try to get imaginary
numbers and don't worry if you don't
know what those means out of radicals
but that's where the conjugate shows up
it's a fancy word but all it means is if
i have a
plus b the conjugate of a plus b is just
a minus b
so literally i just swapped the sign
right over there and why it's good to
multiply an expression like this times
its conjugate is because you end up
getting a difference of squares if you
do a plus b times a minus b and we've
seen this multiple times this is the
same thing this is equal to a squared
minus b squared you can do the
distributive property twice and see how
everything simplifies out it comes out
to a squared minus b squared so let's
apply that right over here in our in the
problem we need to rationalize and
simplify
so let's let's multiply out the let's
multiply the numerator first just so
that's since that's easy so we have x
times this entire expression over here
so we can distribute the x so it's x
times the principal square root of x
that's the x times this right over here
and then we multiply the x times the one
so plus x so that's our numerator and
then our denominator
we have a minus b times a plus b is one
way to view it so that's going to be a
squared so think of it this way
think of this as
a and think of the 1 as a b so this is a
minus b and then this is a
plus b so it's going to be a squared
minus b squared when you multiply it out
you're going to get a difference of
squares so a squared so
if you have the square root of x
squared that's just going to give you x
so this is going to give you
this is going to give you x when you
square this
minus
1 squared well what's 1 squared well
it's just 1.
and so you could say that we are done
but there might be let's see is there
anything more that we could is there
anything more that we could simplify
here well we could factor out an x if we
have factored out an x well then you
just have the x times the square root of
x plus one not clear that you can
simplify it anymore so that's that's
that's about right you could write i
guess one thing that you could write is
you could write this
x times the square root of x you could
write that as since that's x to the
first power times x to the one half
power you could write that as x to the
three halves power not clear if that's
actually a simplification but this is
about as good as you can do at least at
least from my point of view